hello everybody and welcome to the 4th
game development with Python 3 and PI
game tutorial video in our series here
where we left off we could control our
car and move it left or right we have no
boundaries and even if we added
boundaries we have to only add a
boundary but also add some sort of a
handling to say if we hit that boundary
what happens I suppose you could just
make a boundary and just not let the
character go past that boundary a little
more fun to make them crash anyways so
when I say that's a crash if you go off
the screen make it a little more
challenging so with that let's go ahead
and add in some logic here that not only
calculates if we've moved off the screen
but if we have let's go ahead and crash
and then when we crash we have some sort
of you know message that we want to
display to the screen like hey you
crashed idiot and then from there we can
maybe replay or the user could choose to
exit out or whatever so let's go ahead
and do that so to do this we're going to
need to make a few changes to our script
here so we have this sort of wow loop
that we're treating like a game loop but
this isn't really the best way to do it
so we're gonna kind of we're going to
change that so first of all we're going
to say we're going to come down here
we'll take crashed and then we're going
to take this we'll take x and y's
definition we can leave the car image
and we should go to leave like all this
other stuff up here because this stuff
the stuff up here is pretty much like
constants so display width we don't
intend to ever change we don't want to
change height we don't change the color
definitions we don't change the clock
we're not going to change the car image
all that stuff so but the stuff that we
want to truly be variable we have to put
into this game loop so we're going to
say define a game underscore loop and
this all will be our in our game loop
here and that's not including this and
then so we'll highlight everything from
clock tick all the way up to where we
define game loop and at least an ideally
what you can do is hit tab and that will
tab
everything over so anyway that's what
we'll do there and so we'll put up
everything under gameloop now and then
we need to run game loop here so we just
call game underscore loop and so this
runs the game loop for us now just to
make sure we've got everything we're
supposed to have here let's go ahead and
save and run that and make sure that
runs it did not run for us so while not
crashed for whatever reason did not want
to run game loop X Y something here
probably has failed in game loop I
didn't witness any failure there but
let's run it one more time see if we get
a fail
trying to decide what would cause it to
exit like that on us updating game field
white game oh man amateur that's
probably it this game loop just
references the game Lee [ __ ] man quit an
amateur anyway gotta have your
parameters there there we go
it's like freaking out okay so left
right cool so our game loop works as
long as you're not a big idiot like me
yeah so anyway when you want to make a
function run you have to put the empty
parameters behind it or after it rather
okay so our game loop now it is
displayed correctly now next thing we
want to do is we don't necessarily want
to leave the game loop just because we
crashed we only want to really leave our
game loop when um because basically game
loop will continue to run and assume
that whenever game loop is done running
we're going to run quit so if we crash
that's going to quit the game maybe the
user wants to play again so we don't
really want that to be the case anymore
so actually we're going to say we're
going to call we're gonna change crashed
to game exit and then why not
game exit we run this loop so it'll
still run this loop and do all the
things that we wanted to do and now
we're ready to handle specifically the
crash sequence now don't get your hopes
up we're not actually going to have the
car break up or anything feel free to do
that at the end if you want but actually
we just need to handle what happens when
the user crashes so we'll leave that a
good let's let's just check our logic
real quick make sure it works everything
seems to be working so leave for some
reason doesn't want I don't want to exit
though I know why okay so instead it
right so a quick command is still being
called crashed so anyway so we're
assigning true to crashed so that was
the problem so so we have game x equals
false while not game exit but then if
the event type is acquit it has to be
game exit equals true I'd left crash
there the perfect example where you're
like trying to hit the axe and you can't
quit you can do that to your to your
your little gamers too if you want if
you want to be really mean I suppose you
can do that so otherwise we'll just do
this and now let's run it one more time
make sure our exit works and it does
okay so now we're ready that kind of add
um some more logic to things so the
first thing we want to ask is if the car
because we don't have anything to run
into yet but we do have edges and we
want to like enforce crossing over the
edges and we're going to force that with
a crash so we're going to say if the
user crosses over the edge
that's a crash so we'll allow everything
to happen actually I was going to do it
there but we'll allow the change to
occur the game display to update
everything but then again after we've
drawn the car um hmm I was going to let
us do an update but I think after we
draw the car before we do the actual
update what we're going to do is run our
questionnaire basically and this is our
logic basically so this is our event
handler but then we have to handle logic
so an object doesn't actually crash into
an object in any game it doesn't happen
that way instead what happens is objects
kind of overlap each other and if they
overlap we can build some logic that
says hey these objects overlap that's
not possible in the world and we have
some sort of handling for these this
overlapping that's occurred so same
thing here what we're going to ask is if
if the car it's not like it crashes into
the edge of the screen really but if the
car happens to pass over that you know
arbitrary number that we set we're going
to say boom you crashed so it just makes
sense like to make that the edge of the
screen instead of like you know hundred
pixels away from the edge of the screen
just to troll your game players so we're
going to make at the edge of the screen
but you can make it anything really so
we're going to say if X and X is the
location of our car so we're say if X is
greater than the display width so if X
is greater than the display width so
that's how wide our screen is so if it's
greater than how water screen is
but then we have to add another question
to it but I'll show you why in a minute
if so if X is greater than the width or
X is less than zero then we're going to
say you crashed so for here um I really
wanted to show sooner
I guess we'll call a game exit so I'll
just say game x it equals true so I just
want to illustrate something that
happens a lot so game X it equals true
and it will break the game so we'll save
and run that and so x equals zero
happens or over here and then X greater
than display with happens over here so
first I'll show you zero we crashing the
wall game exits as we expected no big
deal but now let me show you why the
other bit of code needs an addition to
it so we're able to do that and we
actually came back so really we have
crashed significantly in the wall I mean
at this point the driver is dead so what
we have to understand is X again is
right here it's this top left corner so
that's why over here it worked but over
here it's not going to work until you're
like all the way over okay
so to remedy that we have to account for
this so the question was if X is greater
than display width but it's not greater
than display with its greater than
display with minus a car width so what's
the width of our car now we have not
defined car with how do we know what the
width of our car is well if we go over
to our image we can find out what the
width of our car is in my case it's you
know the width of your image basically
so after you've made your little image
you're going to want to you know make
the square as tight as you can and my
image width happens to be 73 pixels so
we're going to say car underscore width
equals 73 you need to use what if you
use my image then it's 73 but you would
need to use whatever image of your width
of your image whatever that is so we'll
come back down here and now we've got
car width so now when we run this and we
take our car
and we crash over to the edge we
actually have a true no we crashed so so
it's useful to to include that that
width stuff and it's and you have to
keep this in mind because as you have
objects as well if you just reference X
that object can crash in but as long as
it doesn't cross over the upper left
then you'd be fine in theory so you have
to take this into account as well so
anyway that's our first showing I
thought I was going to also include the
GAMEOVER sequence but I think we'll save
that for another video this one's
already 10 minutes somehow remember how
we how we got to 10 minutes but anyway
so we're going to do the crash sequence
or get really game over sequence in the
next video so stay tuned for that you
guys have any questions or comments as
usual even below and also as usual
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time